le groenland une île qui est recouverte
à 80% de glace voit une diminution
importante de sa calotte glaciaire en
raison de la vague de chaleur qui a
touché l'europe
est-ce qu'il faut s'en inquiéter quel
est l'état actuel de la situation pour
en parler je joins dans notre studio à
québec louis fortier qui directeur
scientifique du réseau arcticnet et du
brise-glace de recherche ngcc amundsen
merci beaucoup monsieur fortier d'être
avec nous bonjour pour bien comprendre
la situation allons-y d'une image très
concrète on parle de 197 milliards de
tonnes de glace qui ont fondu en juillet
au groenland et une autre image pour
comprendre un milliard de tonnes ça
équivaut à 400000 piscine olympique
alors dites nous un peu que les l'état
de la situation actuelle c'est assez
difficile à dire que si l'ensemble pour
donner une autre image une autre idée si
l'ensemble de la calotte glaciaire au
dessus du groenland fondait demain matin
le niveau des océans sur l'ensemble de
la planète ce réseau serait de 7 mètres
ci s'imposera ce qui cause bien
évidemment des problèmes le gigantesque
pour notre civilisation
à l'heure actuelle on voit une
accélération de la fonte ou de faux bien
sûr elle comprendre que le glacier au
dessus du groenland se forme et fond en
même temps c'est à dire que à chaque
année il ya une partie de la nouvelle
neige qui va se transformer en glace
excédera et une partie au fond depuis
plusieurs années depuis une cinquantaine
d'années le
la partie du bilan la forme si on veut
augmenter ses criques et de plus en plus
d'eau qui se retrouvent dans l'océan
atlantique l'océan arctique donc
l'ensemble du niveau des mers
heureusement mais dans ce conte prévoir
et c'est là que ça devient difficile
les études donnent pas les mêmes
résultats
mais ce qu'on prévoit c'est que si la
fin du siècle en 2100 on devrait avoir
une augmentation du niveau des océans de
l'ordre d'un demi mètre causés par le
gouvernement de delhi m jusqu'à jusqu'à
deux mètres ça c'est seulement vous
l'avez dit seulement pour le groenland
c'est vraiment à la fonte de la calotte
glaciaire du groenland
ça serait quoi l'impact sur les villes
et daisy légalement qui pourraient
disparaître tout à fait il ya des jeux
des îles qui sont en train de
disparaître parce qu'on a eu une
augmentation d'environ une douzaine de
centimètres du niveau des océans et des
îles qui sont vraiment menacé il ya des
endroits où le réhaussement est inégalée
des endroits où ça a monté de jusqu'à 1
m il ya des accents texan l'archipel
dans le pacifique
le gouvernement de l'archipel obtenu sa
dernière séance sous l'autre pour deux
pour donner un exemple pour donner en
fait pour avertir la population mondiale
du fait que c'est une réalité le
réchauffe le rehaussement du niveau de
l'océan
vous êtes aux commandes du brise-glace
de recherche ngcc amundsen alors comment
son père vos recherches là sur les
changements climatiques sur le terrain
bien on travaille sur tous les aspects
de du réchauffement planétaire en
articles tous les impacts que ce soit
sur la diminution de la banquise les
packs que sa hausse sur les écosystèmes
marins et aussi sur les services que
rendent ces écosystèmes lancé aux
populations locales
les gens dépendent énormément par
exemple des phoques des poissons des
baleines les bélougas etc des oiseaux
marins également donc on étudie comment
le fait que l'écosystème le bascule vers
un écosystème plus beaux real va
affecter les
les populations locales et avec les
réseaux de centres d'excellence
arcticnet on fait un peu la même chose
sur les écosystèmes terrestres
quel genre d'impact maintenant le canada
pourrait avoir avec de tels changements
lors des prochaines années ce fossile le
canada est évidemment un pays arctiques
c'est peut-être pays article par
excellence
après la russie donc on a un territoire
arctique immense et ce qu'on observe
c'est évidemment la diminution de la
banque est ici mnd des enjeux pour les
populations locales qui dépendent de
cette banquise et aussi pour les
sociétés du sud qui avons voir de
nouvelles voies maritimes s'ouvrir etc
ça va permettre le développement de ce
qu'on appelle une économie bleue
pêcheries transport du minerai 30
tourisme et et une navigation évidemment
on observe également sur le continent la
fonte la déstabilisation du pergélisol
c'est quand même des problèmes énormes
pour les écosystèmes pour les espèces
comme le caribou et c est aussi un
nouveau phénomène depuis quelques années
depuis deux ou trois ans on voit une
augmentation de la fréquence et de
l'intensité des feux en article
absolument et jouer ce jour là c'était
très rapidement que je pense d'ailleurs
on a des images là dessus il ya de très
gros fûts actuellement à sibérie
d'ailleurs les voit les images
l'accident oui c'est la liesse tout est
relié la dalle
toutes les listes un réchauffement
général des températures au niveau du
sol qui font que la banquise voir
disparaître qui font que la toundra va
s'enflammer qui font que le pergélisol
déstabiliser alors ce genre d'image on
risque malheureusement de les revoir
lors des prochaines années tout à fait
et les impacts
locaux sont importants non seulement sur
la faune de la flore mais également sur
les populations locales qui sont
étouffés jusqu'à un certain point par
ces fumées la merci beaucoup monsieur
fortier d'avoir fait le point avec nous
ça fait plaisir
au revoir